I'd like to ask Rosalee first what was
the Eureka moment for finding this book
as a property did someone walk into a
bookstore or someone like you and say
check this out
I'd like to take the credit for finding
the book but in fact it was the script
that came my way Jane Anderson and I had
developed a project together back in the
mid 90s and she came back into my life
when I'm not producing I'm actually a
manager as well and she became a client
and she had written an adaptation of the
wife and it was just fantastic and I
believe it was written when new line had
their specialty division fine line but
fine line was no longer and so the
script was sitting on the shelf at new
line but the book had come out of option
so I'm gonna try and give you the short
version because this was a process of
constantly figuring out how to take the
next step but the first step was to
option the book so that at least we
controlled the underlying rights and it
is a wonderful novel and then I believed
because the film is set largely in
Stockholm that I should have a
Scandinavian partner and I was
introduced to me to fall dejure who was
my partner in making the film and we
agreed to work together even before we
had actually met and as it turned out my
belief that there would be Scandinavian
subsidies to make the film didn't play
out because we weren't Swedish enough to
qualify but I met a wonderful partner in
meter and meter was the one who
introduced me to Bjorn and in the
meantime beautiful Glenn Close had read
the script and had already committed and
it's sort of snowballed from there I
flew to London to meet with various
sales agents and the team at embankment
read the script loved it and they said
we want to be your partners
they were the ones who sold the
international rights and even with all
of that which I think took over - or for
me I think for me a total of four years
but at the eleventh hour we still were
missing a piece of equity finance and
that was provided by Claudia bloom Huber
and silver real so there's that's and
all this wonderful cast and then this
all I'm on board came together and so
for Glenn Close you you saw in the
script what I saw a big challenge in the
script to figure out who this woman was
and it was a situation that I'd you
don't never played a character like it
and I was just fascinated by trying to
figure it out
and for you Jonathan Pryce this is a
character who is admirable on the
outside and what was your word a bastard
something of a bastard or at least
trying to balance his hypocrisy on the
inside what was it like to form this
character for your performance well I
would think particularly easy I drew
from life you have to understand this a
man just played the Pope that's why she
was kissing my ring earlier but no I
read the script and usually when I am
when I look for a script that I want to
do I look for something it doesn't have
all the answers and that you know
especially in in theater I work a lot in
theater and I liked the the audience to
be the other cast member and I think in
this that the script wasn't overwritten
the characters were clearly drawn but it
wasn't overwritten and there was a lot
of room for all of us to to fill out
those characters and of course you I've
played a lot of bad people in my time
but I are using the Pope as well all
right the Pope not
okay you've got to see it that was a
mean cackle anyway but I have always
believed in the people I play and I
believe in the their their truth as they
see it and they are going about their
lives as they say in an honest way and
so I played Joe as honestly as I could
and then it's up to the audience to
decide whether he's a sympathetic
character or why he did what he did and
why his wife stayed with him and so
Buuren how do you direct these scenes
that are so nuanced you know all of this
right below the surface and only a bit
of it can come out at a time without
throwing off the balance of the scene
first it's very much to take care of the
acting energy and I also always I have
worked for many years in Sweden in
Scandinavia but and I like to be I like
to take film from the top to the bottom
every every scene as every retakes is
through the whole scene we never did
inserts so then it you get some kind of
energy if you put if you find the right
celery and the camera is on the right
place is where two cameras and one
leading with the head with one lead
camera scene and the cinematographer
with bronto's and I have collaborated
for many years so we have to find the
scenery and when we have find the center
you find where the camera should be and
then we just investigate the scenes
together with actors and my
responsibility is very much to take care
of their energy into the editing room
Annie you and your mother play the same
character at different ages did you work
together to get a synergy or did you
develop your characters independently no
no this is an incredibly huge
collaborative experience certainly from
the bottom to the top and yeah I was
incredibly interesting and amazing
world to play and this this character is
somebody I will truly kind of cherish
forever but no no she we worked hard on
her we did and did you and and Glenn
perhaps to speak to this did you want a
sense of her as someone who was volcanic
below the surface that her her rage and
her resentment were building or a sense
that this is what a wife dutiful wife
whatever adjective you like would do I
don't know if she would characterize
herself as somebody who's full of rage I
think it's something that that grows
maybe unbeknownst to her because she is
so used to swallowing you know his
behavior and holding the coat and you
know it's not it's a role that she has
accepted until she can't do it anymore
and surprises herself in some ways yeah
I think so I think so yeah it's just a
series of events for Christiane you
played a journalist in interview with
the vampire very different journalist
from this particular role we met and
unhappy and in this one you're sort of a
journalist scholar but still I mean
where are you on the Bill Moyers to Bill
O'Reilly spectrum among this thing in
creating your character yeah it's funny
I do have a new man crush right now
actually and it's it's Jim Acosta
you know from CNN I just love that guy
right come on he's so he's my he's my
new journalistic role model I really do
love that guy but yes it has been a long
journey from interview with the vampire
and you know I've I've had several
interviews since then I think and and I
have picked up different qualities from
each one of those people I tend to be a
observant person and I like to pick up
certain character traits and and I get a
sense of you know certainly the drive
and the ambition and
the need for his own personal gain and
glory possibly at the expense of an
entire family but at the same time you
know like Jonathan was saying I do you
know when you're when you're playing the
character you don't always see him as
particularly mischievous or out to hurt
anybody I mean he has his own agenda and
his own motivations and to a certain
degree not to you know to does horn too
much I think there is a sort of a heroic
quality to this guy I mean it sort it's
inconceivable for him where he is at
this particular point to imagine anybody
not willing to be in the spotlight you
know and and and you know not willing to
take credit for such beautiful work it's
like how could you not you know come on
and so I I appreciated the scene and
it's it's subtleties and and certainly
working with Glenn and Jonathan was was
fantastic we didn't get to work together
but but I loved the whole experience and
Bjorn your wife was the editor and you
have complimentary not come not
competitive functions like the principal
characters here but you had to build
attention and you also leave us with
tension it isn't fully resolved which is
unusual for a film yeah and for me as I
said before the whole shooting is to
collect material emotional material into
the editing process and Lina is sitting
out there in the audience she's the
editor
[Music]
so the best so there we spent the time
and we we go from the script and then
you have to around every you have so
many possibilities and as one yeah you
just have the time the right time and
then you're sculpting and then suddenly
one day after many screenings public
screenings discussions months months
months away suddenly you have something
that is balanced and gives energy so
it's it's very hard to talk about but
for me I think the whole process of
editing is one of the key moments in
filmmaking and then you have the
shooting will be an investigation of the
material and the scenes and we collect
as much as possible of the emotions into
the through the editing room so yeah it
can easily go wrong in the editing room
but it can also as here slowly slowly it
was something that yeah it has good
energy within it well thank you all for
your energy and performance